in this episode of cloud performance
atlas I show how a new load balancer
protocol can give a big performance
boost while we walk the performance high
wire stay tuned to find out as we've
seen before Google clouds networking
suite offers reliable high performing
services for your cloud applications
things like TCP bbr network service
tiers load balancing see DNS DNS the
list goes on the gist is that GCPs
networking services give you a lot of
performance with very little heavy
lifting from your team and that trend
continues recently GCPs load balancer
added support for the quic protocol
quick or quick UDP internet connections
is a modern transport layer protocol
that provides congestion control similar
to TCP and security equivalent to SSL
not to mention improve performance most
of the magic of quic is concentrated on
reducing the number of round trips
required when establishing a new
connection including the handshake step
encryption step and initial data request
which makes it a great option in areas
where you see less than ideal
connectivity from your clients to test
it out we first created a simple HTTP
load balancer that serves a 10 megabyte
file from a GCS bucket then we went into
the console and enabled the quic
negotiation setting for the load
balancer which allows the balancer to
accept quick connections from clients
that support it without disturbing our
existing HTTPS users now it's worth
noting that much like TCP bbr the
benefits of quic are best seen in
situations where clients have poor
connectivity as such to get a true
performance test we simulate a bad
network connection using a TC command
for both our HTTP and quic clients now
on our basic tests quic saw a 1.3 X
improvement in overall performance
versus the standard HTTP on the load
balancer which is pretty nice for just
setting one flag if you're interested to
know more about the quic protocol on GCP
then check out the article linked in the
description below and don't forget to
subscribe to our youtube channel for
more great cloud performance Atlas
content because when it comes to
performance every millisecond counts